(plane flying)
(Captain speaking)
- (sighs)
Okay,
(dramatic music)
- There you go sir.
- Thank you.
- Excuse me.
(BuzzFeed tune)
Oh no.
Mmmm. Mmmmm.
No, no, no.
- Oooh!
- Sorry, I have to...
I am so sorry.
(woman snoring)
(snoring)
Okay.
- Whoa.
- Whoa, sir, sir.
- [Man] I am so sorry.
I am so sorry.
- You're gonna need to sit.
- [Man] It's coming,
I don't wanna pee on...
I'll pee on everyone in this plane!
(baby crying)
Oh, no.
(serious challenging music)
Whoa.
Are you okay?
New boyfriend.
Whoa.
Oh mama!
It stopped. It stopped for a second.
I just have to pee.
I was just making sure
this is upright, locked position.
Oh!
(baby crying)
Whoa!
Okay, I'm sorry.
Uh.
- Oh.
- Oh baby!
This is not fair.
- I just wanna get back to my seat.
- He has a diaper, that's not fair.
- I'm just really trying to...
- We should all be allowed to pee
where we are.
(baby crying)
He smells like baby pee, I need to go.
(screams)
Are you all waiting for the bathroom?
Are you just stretching your legs?
(rock music)
I, mmm, I started the countdown,
and I can't stop it,
and it's coming.
Oh my god.
(sighs)
I have to go again.
(serious challenging music)
(sighs) I think I have
a bladder infection.
(groans) Oh my god.
(BuzzFeed tune)